we pick up in season two basically where
we left off where Lucy has discovered
that she is a purebred rittenhouse much
to her chagrin and that her mother wants
to take her with her aunt and for Lucy
to become part of Britain house and go
on the missions with her and that
everything in Lucy's life has been
leading up to this point but obviously
Lucy's been living a different life
until this point and then we pick up
where Rufus and Wyatt are waiting for
Lucy to take one last mission in the
life but before they blow it up and they
want to go back at Lucy's sister
obviously plans change Lucy never shows
up and at that same time rittenhouse
blows up Mason industries Wyatt Rufus
and the rest of our heroes I survived
unscathed but now they've been moved to
an underground bunker that looks like it
hasn't been touched since the 60s very
apropos and it's called the silo and
this is where everyone lives now great
like timeless and I know - I know it's
awesome you know I mean anybody gets a
little tiresome magic we have to time
travel together we have to wash our
faces together brush our teeth shower
hopefully it's bringing a little bit of
love together for a while and Lucy I
mean I'm liking more I think I see
things going are you a light do you like
light or do you like woo see are you a
light or a wussy you like I kind of like
Lucy - it sounds like woozy um I guess I
I'm definitely rooting for Wyatt and
Lucy and I'm I'm I like lye it and I
like Lucy but I think it's I think it's
really cute that like nobody can
actually really make up their minds
about it and we're where we pick up with
them is is you know why it's getting
some closure around his wife feeling
like okay he's not gonna get her back
and so he's feeling more ready to move
on and I think Lucy is feeling more
ready for Wyatt you know she has never
sister anymore she does of her mom like
she's in a very vulnerable place and why
it is her safe space
right now well I know I'm talking for
myself and Polly many fans I hope that
the tease and the the you know the
teaser premiere that we've seen that
that kiss is not a fake that it's
actually something that you know you'll
have to see but I will say Lucien Wyatt
do go undercover as a new musical duo in
the 40s so they're like the big new
musical theater act or the I guess I
guess they it was a musical theater but
it's the the new musical the big screen
musical duo and so that's pretty funny
that we have to keep up that ruse and
that'll be a fun episode like dance on
how to get my dance get my sing I think
they just got so tired of me singing and
dancing on set all the time I'm like
fine we'll just put it in an episode and
just like keep her quiet for a while
what's your jam my jam my jam I I do I
love old I do love old musicals and I
love old musical movies so we we
actually the 1940s episode where we kind
of traipse around the Paramount lot is
definitely one of my favorites it's old
Hollywood classic I think it's called
Hollywood land and and I and we remade
recreated kind of to our you know to
what we were envisioning the Katherine
have progressed from the Philadelphia
Story so it's really it's got a lot of
great oh magis I think the fans will
really like that one but you'll have to
wait and see we don't I can't tell you
at the Y at Lucy this is real and just
have to have tuned in must be I know you
shot season one in Vancouver but it must
be slightly surreal coming back after
that like small window of cancellation
and then being brought back to life
what's that like been for you okay I was
so interesting when we got canceled it
felt so apropos to the show I mean it
was all the headlines were like it was a
hoax it was it was you know always
renewed it never was canceled it was
absolutely canceled I can tell you that
was one of the should I hold
[Laughter]
I feel like if I were to give you guys a
tour of this would be like Blair Witch
I'm like like hello welcome to this
actually Patterson would have to do it
heat up did but it feels like very Blair
Witch down here likes not dripping and
like the camera like that so welcome to
the silo and time fans here what was
your question again oh yeah that was a
crazy week like that was that was a
roller coaster like I went through a
breakup that week the show guys don't
like it was like such a horrible week
and then I got offered this beautiful
play that my friend Josh Radnor wrote
and I and I was gonna go do that and
then my friend one of my dear friends
had her birthday so celebrated her all
night and then I was flying my mom and
for Mother's Day because I'm like the
show's canceled I'm not going to the
up-front I mean it was absolutely
canceled it was three days of hell and
and then you have to like pull yourself
together and Saturday morning I woke up
and it was like hi hello hey guys they
live here in the silo too yeah just this
is what this is what life's like season
2 of timeless it's people helping us
time travel I woke up Saturday morning
to hundreds of texts and emails and
tweets and I and I didn't know what was
happening I didn't know what was going
on so luckily Sean Ryan and air kripke
our Creator sent us this email with the
headline this is not a hoax time we've
been picked up timeless has been renewed
and I just couldn't believe it because
the fans really brought us back you know
the fans wouldn't have it and it really
shows how we've changed you know social
media and that can give people a real
voice and we were definitely the
benefactors of this love and energy and
and saying no we really want the show
and and who NBC listen thank you thank
you guys thank you for bringing us back
and Bob Greenblatt and Jen Psaki for
listening and they love the show too so
it was really about logistics and
business and and they were able to work
it out and then they wanted us to
announce it but I was sleeping I was
dead asleep and my mom I was like my mom
Mother's Day you know it'll be it'll be
great and I woke up in my whole life
change I kind of felt like Lucy I was
like I woke up at my whole life was
different and my the next year of my
life was different and I was very
grateful and we moved the show to LA and
I'm a mom I have a nine-year-old who's
here in LA so a lot less time travel for
me which is great I can no mean to all
only time travel I don't have to like
actually travel as much satsumas from
Canada that you love think but we love
it thank you yeah I'm speaking of
changes in that just became a yes oh
it's so natural matt is a wonderful
father I knew he'd be a wonderful father
but he found out that they were pregnant
like two days after we got canceled it
was such a crazy week for all of us it
was like so many shifts I was like show
cancelled find out he's pregnant next
day the show gets picked up Amin's moved
to LA so we were we were so we're so
grateful yeah really really grateful and
they're doing great Angela are wonderful
and McKinley is delightful and very but
I think it was mouthing that was saying
he tells bad dad jokes so he was just
like oh he's the worst yeah matt is like
we caught like he is dad joke central
already so he is primed and ready you
know to move into his proper role in the
world so let's talk a little bit more if
you can about season two and I can you
know tell us too much but are we gonna
continue with Rittenhouse is that the
main enemy and talking about sleeper
cells through yeah kind of the structure
of season two is that now that
Rittenhouse has Lucy in their possession
the first mission that Carol's taking
her on is to go get this soldier that's
a very important to Rittenhouse which
Lucy does not know is her
great-grandfather and he's basically the
he is the creator and keeper of
Rittenhouse as we know it today and what
what each episode like if it kind of are
closed ended each episode mission is to
find the Rittenhouse sleeper that they
have left in the past and to try and
stop them from whatever it is they're
doing understand what it is they're
doing and how it kind of goes into their
more master plan so you'll find out in
Episode one of season two that every
episode you know is
they've dropped a sleeper they're from
Rittenhouse and we have to go and kind
of much like Susan one figure it out but
no longer is Flynn our kind of soul bad
guy we actually find out that maybe
Flynn isn't a bad guy he maybe was doing
bad things for a greater good and
potentially even teaming up with him so
we've got that we've got you know the
Lucy and Wyatt love story we've got will
they or won't they Lucy and white love
story should I'd say we we've got Rufus
and Gia are in full-blown relationship
and how that affects everybody around
them and also you remember Gia when we
left off in season one she started she
had this like strange vision so we
explore what's going on with her visions
everybody's we're tracking everybody's
storylines as we go along and really
that I think the big headline for Lucy
is who is Lucy you know with the woman
who she thought she was in season one
her mission to keep history the same and
try and not move anything around so that
nothing was catastrophic Lee going to
change like her sister PMSing has
changed for her now she realizes
everything is so much more fragile and
the deeper reason she has to go in these
missions is stopped Rittenhouse so she's
really using her historical knowledge to
help stop Rittenhouse instead of to not
change history